how big is the moon in the night sky the
moon seems rather small but in reality
it really isn't Central Europe would
easily fit under it the surface area of
the moon is huge to give you some
perspective it's as big as the whole
European continent China the USA Brazil
and South Africa together
weight-wise the moon is only about 180
month of the mass of Earth but how big
is it in relation to earth quite big
actually our Moon is the biggest in the
solar system in relation to its planet
and it's the fifth largest moon in the
solar system quite a bit bigger than the
dwarf planet Pluto now if the moon is
really that huge how far away is it from
us to seem this small in the night sky
three hundred and seventy kilometers as
far as the ISS maybe no at that distance
gravitational forces would rip the moon
apart at 36,000 kilometers it would be
as far away as our most distant
satellites let's adjust the distance to
reality pretty far away right a 747
would need 28 straight days to fly to
the moon and even with our current
technology we'd need two full days and
in a car a lot of time so how big is the
moon well that kind of depends how you
define big
but seriously though it's pretty big hey
YouTube will try something new this
month moon May 1 video about cool moon
stuff each Monday in May so see you next
week
[Music]